everybody today benefits from giving  things away for free  and because the system is in a way where  you have to get reelected every four  years the right person and the right  policies to fix this would never get  elected today so so in order for this to  get fixed you need you need 20 years of  President House and Senate to all be  bought into paying off the national debt  to even address this issue it's not  going to happen because those policies  will never get somebody to say oh so  what we need to do is stop spending what  we need to do is keep a reasonable  interest rate up and what we need to do  is stop trying to chase all these other  things for how long 20 years I'm all in  let's go do it and pay off our debt  people are not going to buy into that